My one time.
I was at a strip club when I was 21 dude and my friend was there and he was 20
and he went up to the bro. I don't go up to the stage.
I chill back like a mob boss. When I go to the strip club,
haven't been in a long time, but when I go, I sit back like a mob boss, man.
You think I don't cross my legs at the strip club. Oh bro. You're crazy, man.
I cross one leg over my onto my leg.
I'm real British at the strip club dude, but I'm also an Italian mobster dude.
And I lay back and I sip a club soda or nothing. Dude.
I got to feel good in my environment.
One of the reasons why I don't smoke is cause I, I didn't need to,
I don't want to have to do when I take a break.
I want you to know I'm taking a break.
I don't want always got to go do something. No, no, no, no. Dude.
I straight up got to get away if I'm at a party,
which I never am.
If I'm at a party and some going on and I got to take a break,
I go outside and I await dude. I feel it in my body.
I used to be uncomfortable taking a break. I didn't have a cigarette.
I wasn't checking my cell phone. They weren't around cell phones.
Weren't around. And now cell phones around. Sometimes I took my cell phone,
but you best believe I could just take a break,
sit outside and wait with my hands in my pockets. People like, what's he doing?
Just staring at the sky, man. That's a break.
I'm not fidgety, dude. I'm not fidgety.
Learn that from my dad. He just chills. And that's the thing. I uh,
so I would go to the strip club and sit back like a mob boss, dude.
And then in the, on the, on the, uh, on the, um, on the stage,
some people would do go walk up to the stage and sit at the stage.
And one time my friend, he was 20. I was 21. He was 20.
He walked up to this stage and he put his fevers.
Like his face was all up in it. And the girl was dancing around like that.
And she was excusing her boobs and stuff. So juvenile. And by the way,
what word do you use for to not sound like a creep for real
boobs. I'm 39 T if I say yeah, her were good.
I seem like a Crip. If I say, yeah, our boobs, what am I? 12? What do you say?
Jugs? You sound like a. You know what I mean? Breasts.
Then you sound like, what are you doing? You try not to sound like a creep,
which makes it creepier. So what the is it? Come up with some Tatas.
Then you're just an. You know what I mean? Like cringe. I'm going to say
[inaudible]. That's what I'm going to say. Ah, yeah. Did you see your booboo
bullies at least then I'm owning it bro. [inaudible].
Okay.
Booby. Luby's that's what I'm going to.
Uh, anyway, we're at the strip club and she was working it.
This was before twerk and she was just regular work in it, not to work in it.
And she was just moving her booby Luby's around and just holding them,
the booby Luby's and sitting around and gyrating and.
And I'm sitting back in a mob dos, like I had a cigarette, but I didn't. Okay.
I was just chilling B and me being inside me.
You understand reveling in it.
I was my body inside my body. You understand? I'm a author.
And I was watching my buddy going like this, his face.
So close to booby. Luby's right. And he was,
and she was doing the thing and she brings her booby Luby's over to him.
And I see it from afar. Okay. Like a, my bus.
And.
I see some go down and then he backs up a little bit casually.
And then he walks over to me and my other buddy, who I was with.
And my other buddy was a really tall,
big guy that has nothing to do with this story.
But I want you to know a little bit about the surroundings.
So he walks up to me and this guy was a little guy and that has nothing to do
with the story. But I want you to understand the color of the seat.
He walks up to me and something's wrong. Okay.
Now I know something's wrong because I know my friend,
but I also know something's wrong because you don't sit at the
stage at the strip club,
especially alone.
Now.
He walks up to me and he says, guys, I don't know what to say.
And I don't know how to say it.
[Inaudible].
And we lean forward, like, yes,
because we want to hear it because we want to die of laughter.
And he says, but it's true.
She escorted her breast milk in my, in my, at my nose.
And it dripped in my mouth a little bit. Oh, that's what he said, dude,
that's the sentence he said, and I never forgot it.
She squirted her breast milk on my nose and it got in my mouth a little bit.
And that was the sentence said, and I never forgot it.
There's only before or after that moment in my life.
And there's only before or after that moment in [inaudible]. Cause
he drank not his mom's breasts.
Okay.
And dude, we fell out me and the big guy.
We fell out.
Our mob boss, chillin was all tattered.
We fell out. We were again 12.
And then the best part was he told us after she did it, he,
she squeezed it like a, like as fruit. And it shot out, hit his nose.
I went into his mouth a little bit and do it. She, she, after that,
she goes like this
and did a finger up to his thing. Her, her mouth, like she, like, he was like,
he was talking at the L in the library,
like it was a treat for him. Hey lady,
don't squirt milk in my nose. Especially if it comes from your body,
B a U D Y dude,
not a turn-on.
Then we told it to another one of our buddies later. And he was like,
I think I'd like that. K.
And we were like, what, bro? He was like, I don't know.
It kind of turned me on once I was with a girl who was recently a mom and,
and mil and I drank it a little bit out of her and it kind of turned me on and I
was like.
Uh.
Drive by
single-shot F it wasn't even a automatic from an automatic rifle.
It was a.
Uh.
Dude, are you kidding, man? What the?
Uh, God dude, strip clubs shenanigans. So funny, man.